I know mr. De Niro my name is Bradley
Cooper my question is regarding
awakenings and I remember thinking if
this doesn't work maybe I'm not right
for this business I thought you know
people you need a vacation or something
I don't defecation from what and I think
that if you love what you do isn't it
isn't it hard to be an [ __ ] I don't
know I mean he's one of the highest-paid
actors in the world and has been
nominated for four Academy Awards his
breakthrough came in 2009 with his film
The Hangover Time magazine named him in
2015 one of the 100 most influential
people in the world
he's Bradley Cooper and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success rule
number four is my personal favorite and
I'm curious if you grow which one you
guys like the best also as Bradley's
talking if he says something that really
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I'm a one-time role on Sex in the City
you know what I gotta go home no way I'm
not letting you out my shirt didn't have
enough ice cream on to his recurring one
on aliens bit parts and movies but it
all changed six years ago there were
night before of us will ever forget with
the Hangout how does one go from the
hangover movies to these very serious in
part dark characters in some way well um
I don't see any difference at all
huh I don't I mean Phil Phil Winnick to
me was a real character that wasn't me
mmm Tracy its Phil and Todd Phillips is
an auteur director and Zack elephant
oxen ed helms are as good as Christian
Bale and Jeremy Renner I mean those guys
are serious gangster actors I mean they
are no joke and you got to bring it hard
every time you're with them so I
actually see it as it's the same thing
I know mr. DeNiro my name is Bradley
Cooper my question is regarding
awakenings I wanted desperately to ask a
question I was terrified and I want to
ask the specific random question about
awakenings and right before it came to
my because I you have to say before they
once when they passed you the mic so I I
thought oh this is gonna be a stupid
question and he's going to say why would
you ask that stupid question and and so
I thought I'll just ask some [ __ ]
question about the mission and riding a
horse and then and then somebody would
have been asked a question about the
mission right before I question I don't
know and the next thing I know it's my
turn I'm standing up and I'm looking at
my idol across you know 40 30 feet away
and then I just asked the question that
I wanted to about awakenings and and he
said good question hmm
and and it like blew me away and I
thought it was just a little reminder
like you know just go with your gut you
know there's a reason why you think the
way you do and want to do the things you
do and you just can't let anybody tell
you don't do it but especially you don't
allow you to tell you not to do it
mmm yeah the loudest voice that that's a
contrarian is usually me and it all
these little moments
confirmation that that voice should just
shut up allows you to just do what
you're supposed to do while you're here
between those things you also went to
Broadway with Julie Roberts with Paul
Rudd three days of rain that must have
been pretty special yeah it was a
do-or-die moment for me actually I think
Kitchen Confidential had gotten canceled
you know I and and I remember thinking
if this doesn't work maybe I'm not right
for this business I thought I thought
that their moments in life anything like
you know it kind of does matter if this
fails or you fail in it and and it was
hard it was one of those was the hardest
thing I've ever been through by far and
I remember thinking if I can get through
this I don't it may be as hard but
there's it's impossible for it to be
harder and it's true and it's and I've
had a lot of hard time since and poor
jobs you know when you're like wow the
pressure is so intense but it always I
have such a foundation for three days
gonna say that eight shows a week right
not even that actually was the rehearsal
process and I have to do once we got on
stage it flew and that thank God and I
thought oh this feels right but there
was a you know and I was hard on myself
you know but it was just man it was
tough the Elephant Man has been a huge
success
smashing attendance records and winning
Cooper excellent reviews from Broadway's
toughest critics for a role that's been
part of his consciousness for decades at
age 12 he decided he wanted to be an
actor after watching the movie version
it tells the story of John Merrick a
horribly deformed British man with a
saintly soul was rescued from a
nineteenth-century freakshow and given
sanctuary of the London hospital
twenty-eight years later Cooper has
produced cast and arranged the financing
for the current Broadway production you
play John Merrick yeah without any
makeup without any prosthesis mmm-hmm
just you Bradley Cooper yeah and you
have to convince the audience that
you're him yeah how do you do that by
believing I'm him that's how I do it if
I'm acting like I'm in or I don't quite
make that leap of faith there's
absolutely no way you're going to
believe it
I had to do a tremendous amount of work
to get to a place where I do believe I'm
him part of the work was 20 years of
research and part of it a performance
unlike he's ever given the
transformation from Cooper to merit is
shared by the audience in one of the
early scenes as the doctor is speaking
to the pathological society which
actually is the audience of the play and
you see an actual photograph of Joseph
Merrick he is then describing all of his
afflictions from the upper jaw projected
another massive bone and then I then
interpret each one in a physical manner
the right hand was large and clumsy a
fin or paddle rather than a hand almost
mimicry almost like a mime to add a
further burden to his travel the
wretched man when a boy developed hip
disease which left him permanently lame
so that he could only walk this day and
once he's finished with that
presentation
I'm fully physically transformed but the
soul hasn't been injected yet he brings
the cane over steps away and then says
please me and that's the first time you
hear America alive that is the moment
where the transformation occurs and if I
don't make that leap at that moment the
rest of the play is not going to work
absolutely I try to find different
things for no other reason than to
further explore you know I have no
desire to repeat anything and I want to
constantly learn now I'm in a situation
where I'm very lucky right now and it
won't last forever it may not last
another year but to be really at a place
where you know it's not just about you
know because for a while just I just got
to get a job and now you know for as
long as it lasts it's like well able to
you know read a book like American
sniper and then try to produce it and
and and and could go to a director like
Clint Eastwood I mean these are things
that if you told me that as a young
actor in grad school I would you got to
be joking but that said you know I
remember being on alias and I was
playing this character
who was you know only good it felt like
and and I remember feeling like I gotta
play something else and really being so
grateful that I got the role in wedding
crashes where he was so diametrically
opposed to that character and I thought
Hurley on like don't you know really
keep trying to go here and here and I
used to iced I always remember Willem
Dafoe came to our school and talked
about how he only takes roles that scare
him and I remember thinking our roles of
scaring roles are the things you can't
do and I thought like oh I think I would
only want to do things that I thought I
could do and and and it was interesting
that I used to think that and and now
it's more like things that scare me I
mean Chris Kyle if you told me I could
have played him I didn't even when we
were developing I thought well I'll just
develop the material and tell the studio
that I'll play him but really I won't
play him I'll get some another actor who
I thought would have been perfect for it
honestly yeah and and and fill with the
hangover it was funny that you mentioned
that because we were talked saying that
I saw last night I was telling my friend
I thought you know looking at that guy
then I was so opposite of that guy
because I was going to give up the
business I was doing a play at
Williamstown and I thought I just can't
it's not going to be it's not going to
happen because I knew that I only wanted
to really be in the middle of
storytelling I really wanted I loved
making a movie I don't love just acting
but I loved the whole thing and in Todd
Phillips called me and said there email
me and said let's do this [ __ ] and
and then and so and then we were filming
it and and I remember and Phil's like
this very confident guy and I was at a
point my life with I would say and I'm
with these massive you know juggernaut
comedians who were crushing it and for
Phil to come off the way he did
I remember that I felt like that was
like you know I don't know how that
happened because I wasn't in that place
so I always feel like that I try to do
things that don't come easy but that
only happened later you know people know
you need a vacation or something I don't
have a km from what I love my life I
feel I'm healthy thank God and you know
I have these incredible directors that
that are interested in working with me
and I'm going to jump at that as long as
there's enough time to prep and I feel
like I can add to it you know yeah yeah
for sure has it changed in terms I guess
there's a point where you don't have to
chase quite as hard
you know it depends on the project I
still shade I wrote an email to a
director about six months ago about a
project that I just felt so connected to
and never got a response that's so
surprising yeah but you know you never
you know it's yeah you just think
professional courtesy would be enough to
oh not in this business you have a
career idea in your head or you have you
you have a mindset about your no I mean
yeah I do my mindset is so simple I just
want to get better I want to get better
and I want to work with great people
it's really simple do you want to be
pushed in new directions all the time
are you I don't want to be pushed I
think I'd push myself so that I never
have a pretty strong engine of wanting
to grow so the no nothing although David
it's a good example I didn't think I
could do that role and he there was an
example of a director saying just walk
with me you know you know we're gonna do
another movie together in the spring
where he's it's the same thing it's a
it's a difficult character my room we're
in Englewood at the hospital and you
spoke so house you were so nice and I
remember meeting me be worth you know
you greeted us and I was only God he's
such an alien actor a principal and he's
so nice what's back now so my question
is how do you stay so kind
well you know I think their question
perplexes me at the root and I maybe
that's why is because why wouldn't I be
dude yeah but I mean but uh I don't know
but I mean like your human being uh
we're all on set together try and tell
the story to me it's always very clear
and that's the real truth everything
else is a sort of artificial branding or
or that ladder sort of work but I don't
know what that means but you have to say
and so I don't know I just I'm always
happy to see another human being on a
set that we're going to tell a story
with together with I mean that I and I
maybe it's because I love what I do I
absolutely love it you know and I think
that if you love what you do isn't it
isn't it hard to be an [ __ ] I don't
know I mean and I'm also grateful it's
like it's not lost on me that to be able
to do this you know we're lucky we're so
lucky so if you you have no ego about
seeing yourself on the screen at this
point or no in a positive I'm in a
negative way no I'm no I well I was
watching themselves well no I don't have
a hard time at all watching myself for
the honesty of a moment of that's an
actor like seeing as that's [ __ ] or
that's working or not I could totally do
that I think objectively I don't ask me
to tell you what I look like on screen
I'm sure what I've managed to do is
divorce myself from the utter shock of
how I because I do in my initial thing
right away I go how do I make a living
it is like it's just a joke I really do
I look at the way I look I mean it I
don't know if most people but that's
just the way I feel but at least I've
divorced myself from that dude I mean I
like okay that's I don't even think
about that anymore so and then I just
focus on the work had you worked with De
Niro before this film anywhere no ed you
had you met him anywhere oh gosh well
I've that on the show when I met him
then I I had a whole long history that
he wasn't aware of that I I auditioned
for up for a movie I put myself on tape
for a movie that to play his son of my
mother
my mother played him and he actually saw
the tape and called me in to meet him oh
that's nice yeah that was yeah that was
and I was a mess I couldn't believe it
and I sat down and he just said he
didn't say much he just said yeah I see
it I see you I I see it okay yeah I mean
but I've worked with some Eno and Wilson
that say you can't you know Dana loved
Hall Pass great jason sudeikis wonderful
funny terror
[Music]
let me ask you there was a rumor going
around that I believed that a lot of
people in the business believed that
President Clinton was in the hangover
too I was reading it in the trades they
were saying he's going to have a camión
hangover too you know
how was that started that rumor the real
is we were in Bangkok Clinton was there
with his fund of giving a speech of Zack
and Todd and I went to see him speak and
then they said hey do you want to have
dinner with the president
afterwards I don't my god would be great
so then we had dinner with him and he
was late and I just have to get be lucky
I was sitting next to the empty chair
yeah it was so crazy the first thing he
said to me walked out he's like all I
want to know is there gonna be an 18-2
and can I be in it literally is what I
thought are you messing with me me yeah
yeah I get you it underperform you don't
have to embarrass me in front of the
table but you didn't mean it
but yes you do impressions about gravity
sometimes if you want me to talk I just
whatever comes into my head I say no no
when or what it's gonna be
Walter's mother thank you guys so much
for watching
I made this beauty because Bradley girl
999 asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I also love to
know what did he say that had the
biggest impact on you what message meant
the most to you please leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shadow to Roger Pierce and his
cartoon Sully startup he made a cartoon
strip about me and my one word the book
signing and I really appreciate that
Roger feeling the love man thank you for
the support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon